hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast highly multiplexed single cell
analysis of tumor heterogeneity through
time and space by mass citometry I am
Judy orbits.com and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labroots and
sponsored by self signaling technology
self signaling technology is a private
family-owned company founded by
scientists and dedicated to providing
highquality research tools to the
biomedic research Community the
company's employees operate worldwide
from its US headquarters in
Massachusetts and offices in the
Netherlands China and Japan for more
information visit
www.el signal.com we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can and you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
located in the lower left of the
window this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C button
located in the bottom lefthand corner of
your web page and follow the process of
obtaining your credits I would now like
to introduce today's first Speaker Randy
Wetzel director of cytometry at sell
signaling technology Dr Wetzel received
his PhD in Neuroscience from Boston
University he then worked as a research
fellow at Harvard Medical School
Massachusetts General Hospital before
joining cell signaling technology in
2002 he is currently the director of
cytometry at cell signaling technology
where he oversees antibody testing and
validation in imaging and flow
cytometric applications I will now turn
it over to Dr wetle for his
presentation thank you Judy and and
thank you all for attending this webinar
today I I hope you find the content as
exciting uh as as I do um so we're
talking about IHC today and uh there are
a number of different methods for this
whether you do chromogenic IHC as on the
left in this image Multiplex imop
florescent IHC as in the the center
image or the very highx Imaging math
citometry and this image from bar on on
the right uh regardless of of which of
those you do I think it's it's critical
to remember that you have to use
antibodies that are specific and by that
I mean that they bind to specifically
only to the Target of interest and they
don't B to other other proteins that
might be present in the tissues so the
Protein that's imaged in the brown on
the left and in the green in the center
is is a well studied protein called pdl1
and if you were looking to set up a
study like this you might be looking out
uh to find a pdl1 antibody and here are
uh is some chromogenic IC data with two
commercially available pdl1 monol
antibodies and as you can see they both
stain p pdl1 positive lung tumor tissue
however the one on the right also stains
pdl1 negative breast tumor So This Is
Not pdl1 So based on this information
you would hopefully choose the antibody
on the left and and not the antibody on
the right however uh it's not always
clear when antibodies are non-specific
and often these antibodies are used in
studies and then published and and uh
subsequent researches based on those
Publications and this has led to a big
problem with uh irreproducibility this
is really highlighted by by two eye
openening papers from 2011 in
2012 in which scientists at two
different pharmaceutical companies bear
on the left and Amgen on the right were
looking at how often they had trouble
reproducing published studies when
they're working on their their
translational assays and surprisingly uh
one found that 2third of the projects
had inconsistencies between the public
data and their own in-house data at anen
it was even more startling they were
only able to confirm the scientific
findings in the Publications 11% of the
time so this means that there's a lot of
ir reproducible studies out there and
the cause of that is really varies from
um you know maybe not using proper
positive and negative controls maybe a
little bias in the in the pressure to
publish uh but at least some of this is
due to bad antibodies it's been
estimated that uh of of the spend on on
protein binding reagents approximately
half of that is wasted on bad antibodies
this is about $350 million in the US or
the equivalent of $800 million US dollar
globally so this is a big problem and
and it's it's a little confusing in in
the market space out there because you
see lots of companies talking about
validation but I think the biggest
problem is that there isn't a clear
defition as as this quote reads from
from a uh this is from a David Rim paper
a few years ago there are no universally
accepted guidelines or standard methods
for determining the validity of these
reagents so as you look around as a
scientist you see different vendor
websites and they have words about
validation and testing they may even
have a stamp or a seal of approval but
as a scientist I would urge you to be
cautious about that and to do a little
investigation to look at who who's doing
the validation what are the testers
qualifications what were the testing
models used and and most importantly did
they use appropriate positive and
negative controls so as Judy mentioned
my role here at self- signaling
technology is in testing and validating
antibodies and we have a a pretty
rigorous validation Paradigm um that
that I believe is is pretty tight so the
the key to it is concurrent testing on a
number of different applications so
often in an body will look okay on one
application and you won't see a problem
until you put it on a different
application we also use Target specific
modulation so uh in other words using
different lians or Inhibitors to alter
the activity expression or localization
of a protein and then we'll look at that
and say you know is this what I expect
um we stain positive and negative cells
or tissues when they're available and
when they're not we can generate
knockout or or crisper models to to
Really strengthen our Val validation and
equally important as new lots of
antibodies are released they're retested
in all of the applications again to
verify that nothing has
changed uh so um here's an example of
some data that came in these are real
data that came uh these four clones came
up to our group for testing clone a b c
and d and uh they're shown here with
with Western data on four different cell
lines each and you can see they look
pretty comparable the molecular weight
are about the same size however when we
put these clones on just simple uh
immunocyto chemistry you can already see
differences in the staining pattern
between the Clones that's not Apparent
at the Western level and so it's this
combination of of concurrent testing on
multiple applications that really
strengthens uh our our feeling that the
the antibodies are specific and I'm I'm
very proud of what we do and and I think
it's recognized in the industry in in
the most recent bio compare research
antibody user survey CST was ranked
number one in terms of antibod
specificity sensitivity and
reproducibility and and I believe it's
from from our um rigorous validation
Paradigm here recently this subject of
of antibody reproducibility was raised
at at a fbl conference at ayar in
California this was a meeting toward the
end of last year where experts from
across the field including antibody
vendors and scientists that use these
antibodies met to talk about antibody
validation and and what's causing the
problem and as a result of that a
terrific paper came out right at the end
of last year published in nature methods
where the authors it was a team of of
experts um described a a testing
Paradigm that we should all use to to
look at our antibodies and they refer to
this as the five pillars of antibody
validation and at least the the four on
the left in this slide are relevant for
for what we're discussing today IC so
the first is is genetic and this is this
can include things like using sna to
knock out the Target and do you see your
stain go away orthogonal studies like
Mass Spec to confirm that the expression
you see with your antibody matches the
the the protein expression by MPC also
using an independent antibody so using
another antibody against the same Target
do you see the same expression pattern
and localization and finally uh if if
it's available at a tagged Express
protein to show that my antibody is
capable of staining this protein so it's
the same kind of idea of using multiple
applications at the same time to to
Really solidify the validation of these
antibodies so just because an antibody
is specific and validated though does
not mean it will always work sometimes
it's possible to get bad data with good
antibodies if they're misused and one
example is um not following the
recommended protocol so antibody
performance can really vary if if you
use a different fixative or different
conditions of staining and it's
important to follow the recommended
protocol also using the antibody in an
application that is not recommended or
supported for example if an antibody is
validated for flow cytometry or
immunocytochemistry does not mean it's
going to work in formal and fixed
paraffin embedded
tissue poor sample quality or sample
preparation as always can can uh can
negatively impact your results or the
the quality of the other reagents that
you're using in your
staying so with that I'm going to pause
and uh hand over the mic to my colleague
and zurk who will uh show us his amazing
data uh using Imaging Mass citometry
thank you Dr westle for that informative
presentation and now I would like to
introduce Dr Baron Gooden Miller
Professor for quantitative biology at
the University of Zurich Professor bu
Miller studied biochemistry at the
University of Roy and eth Zurich and
obtained his PhD for his work on
systemwide signaling network analysis in
the laboratory of Rudy abols at eth zurk
for his post-doctoral training he joined
the laboratory of Gary P Nolan at
Stanford University there he developed
methods for the high throughput analysis
of signaling Network states by mass
citometry a technology that allows in
principle to quantify 135 proteins and
signaling molecules at the Single Cell
level in 2012 he became group leader and
in 2013 SNF ERC assistant professor at
The Institute of molecular Life Sciences
at the University of Zurich currently
his group is developing methods for
highly multiplexed Imaging by Mass
citometry to unravel how transcellular
signaling signaling Network interactions
in the tumor micro environment Drive
cancer development and ultimately might
be exploited for therapeutic targeting I
will now turn it over to Professor Bud
Miller for his presentation
thank you for your nice introduction and
also I would like to to thank uh CST for
offering me uh or for providing me the
opportunity to present uh some of the
work that we are doing in in my group
here at University of
Turk so as the title already says this
presentation will focus on the highly
multilex analysis of tissues by uh
Imaging Mass hometry
so it is very obvious to all of us that
tissues are at the center of life
science research because any type of
disease happens in a tissue either uh it
originates in a tissue or it
nevertheless happens in a tissue such
like an infection now one disease we
have a particular interest in that is
originating in the tissue is cancer and
you can see see here on the slide that
typically in cancer when can find
different tumor cell phenotypes as well
as multiple immune cells and strer cells
that have infiltrated the tumor and I
think it is uh clear to everyone that in
order to study such a complex tissue
such as the tumor but also any other
tissue what you would like to have is a
comprehensive measurement that allows us
to distinguish all of these cell types
as well as to infer the functional state
of of these cells but now let's look at
how these measurements are actually done
for example in the clinics and in many
research groups there is still rou tee
work uh to do an H&D stain where one can
see the distribution of proteins and
nucleic acids uh to learn about the
morphology of a tissue and I'm always
impressed about how much pathologist can
tell me about a tissue simply by looking
at such an h&
stain now another technique uh that is
extremely widely used is IM histo
chemistry um where you see the
distribution and the abundance of a
single epitope typically a protein and I
think every mediumsized hospital makes
millions of those stains every year uh
to assess the disease uh of the diseases
of of the patients and then there's also
um in some specialized labs and in very
few hospitals there's actually Multiplex
flid resence microscopy used that two
per sometimes five markers are
visualized at the same time however if
you now think again about uh the tumor
that I've just shown you to truly
comprehend its composition and to study
it what you really need are highly
multiplexed measurements with spatial
resolution of a tissue and in an Ideal
World what I would like to measure is
the genotype the transcript home the
proteins the signaling Network State uh
lipids metabolites Etc and of course in
the moment that is not feasible yet but
let's assume we can do highly Multiplex
images of such tissues then we can also
identify the boundaries of individual
cells then we can learn about cell types
and their Stace and as we have an image
we can also learn about the local
structure and arrangements and cellto
cell interactions that happen in these
tissues
now let's assume we can generate these
three levels of information then
together with patient data what this
will yield does immediately is
information about the underlying biology
because compared to a A proteomics or
genomics measurement that is performed
on bulk cell samples here we not only
get a long list of Market that are up
and down regulated but we immediately
see them in the context of cell types
many of which we know and in the context
of other cells so we can readily place
what we see uh in the context of known
biology and understanding biology is
always the basis for truck discovery of
to improve uh uh existing truck regimens
and also if we have such Imaging
techniques we can also use it to assess
the efficacy of a truck and if we now
assume that we can generate such es um
of a high number of patients then I'm
very very confident that the information
about many markers cell types
interstates and cellto cell interactions
will be much more informative to
stratify those patients uh compared to a
single stain as it's done in IFC
alone and what I believe what will
happen in the long term with this highly
Multiplex tissue analysis method and the
one that I present you today is just one
of sever
that are actually currently uh are being
developed is that these techniques will
be used for a more accurate
classification of the patients to give
them an accurate prognosis to choose the
best possible treatment and along the
way then also to assess the treatment uh
efficacy now in order to perform such
highly multiplexed measurements we need
a technology that allows for highly
multiplexed readouts and in an Ideal
World we also want to have those
measurements in a targeted manner
meaning that we can predefine a list of
proteins phosphation sites and other
markers that we're interested in and
then we can measure them in a targeted
manner in a tissue so I think most of
you have already heard about Mass
citometry uh it's uh in its original
iteration a technology that is similar
to flow hometry in that uh you take
cells and suspension and then you stain
those cell cells using
antibodies however now what is unique to
myometry and that is very important for
you to understand to approach is that
that an antibody with a defined
specificity is labeled with a metal
isotope of a defined mass and this mass
in the end will be the reporter that you
read out so then the next step mean
check those single cells into the
mometer here they enter so-called plasma
uh what is a plasma the fourth set of
matter you probably remember from your
studies there's solid liquid gas and
plasma you always have to increase the
amount of energy you add to the system
to reach a plasma and I think the most
famous plasma that we all know is
actually the
Sun and like the sun um also the plasma
in the mometer is actually pretty hot
it's about
8,000 uh degree celsius and so when a
single cell now enters uh the plasma it
is adom and most of the atoms are
ionized and this generates a single cell
ion Cloud which is analyzed and using a
mass spectrometer and the result is
shown to the lower left in this slide is
that of every single cell we measure the
distribution and the abundance of the
metal isotopes that were bound to the
single cells by the antibodies and we of
course know for every isotope to which
antibody it was bound to and therefore
we can learn about the cell type
signaling and functional state of those
single cells in a targeted
Manner and uh at least theoretically the
mometer provides 135 simultaneous uh
measurement
channels so why do we use Isotopes as
reporters um the most common report of
symbology are probably flu Force however
as you can see in the lower left of this
they have FR broad emission Spectra M
measure several antibodies with flu
Force attached to them those Spectra
start to overlap and eventually it
becomes quite challenging to tell thanks
to this overlap a part uh at a given
wavelength from which flu for the signal
was actually coming from now by
replacing those Fluor if metals and
atomic M spectrometry we by and Loud
solve the problem of the overlapping
channels and KN can measure many more uh
molecules simultaneously on the Single
Cell
level now the second part of the talk
when we talk about Imaging Mass ometry
you will also see that using Metals
instead of FL force of fluoresence as a
read out also solves us the problem of
the backround fluoresence that we can
find in tissues and that is quite
traumatic in some tissue
types so here the current status of
suspension based m ometry in the
experiments that you perform uh in my
lab we always determine the cability the
cell size and volume the D content and
the cell cycle state in addition we can
measure 52 antibodies
simultaneously and we can measure about
a th000 cells per second and this
measurement speed can be maintained over
hours so there is no problem to analyze
millions of
cells the detection limit is about 100
copies uh of a of an epito per cell at
least on on paper then we can analyze
hundreds of samples uh a day we have
developed protocols uh to do this and we
for example run screening experiments
where we really analyze thousands of
samples within a few days and then there
are a minimum of I would say 400
antibodies that now have been validated
for
myometry now the caveat or limitation of
M hometry are threefold first the cells
are atomized meaning it will always and
only be an endpoint measurement so you
cannot use it to sort cells and do a
followup
experiments we also do not gain any Life
Cell information and to understand many
biological
processes uh this is actually
important and then we have to rely uh on
antibodies um and as Dr already pointed
out the number of antibodies that is
available um that is of high quality
reproducible and highly specific um is
is in some sense the limited or for my
view we don't have such an antibody for
every single protein yet of the human
prodium okay so now what I explained you
so far um showed how we can use myometry
to analyze cells in suspension and I
would now like uh to come back to the
question of analyzing or the problem of
analizing a tumor or a tissue we can do
this with suspension
myometry but then we have to generate
single cell suspensions from a given
tumor or tissue to then analyze it by
myometry and when I started my group
here uh in syc I was thinking about how
could you use mom
Ain to a
microscope and the idea that I got when
I was visiting by chance a group here at
D Tu um called de Gunter when I visited
de Gunter um he's a specialist for laser
BL Technologies they had really occurred
to me that the most feasible way to
introduce a tissue akin to single cells
into the mometer would be using L
opulation
Technologies and so what we then
developed is what we call Imaging
myometry and in imaging myometry we take
routin tissue sections we stain those
sections with the antibodies that carry
the pure metal Isotopes then you use a
laser BL system and this laser then
shoots on a very small area on the
tissue let's say a square micrometer and
in this very small area all of the
tissues removed we generate a cloud of
very small tissue particles and now this
cloud of these particles is introduced
into the mometer akin to an individual
cell and then the process is like I've
explained to you before uh however now
we determine the distribution and the
abundance of metal Isotopes not for an
individual cell but for a distinct
location on the tissue and here I would
like to stress is that the laser doesn't
just shoot one once and then we measure
but this laser continuously shoots with
several hundred Hertz and scans over the
tissue line by line by line to generate
the images uh that we are uh to generate
the in images of the tissues that we
interested
in and all in all we can also image 52
markers
simultaneously uh currently in the
tissue by Imaging Mass
hometry so besides that my left has
developed a complete workflow for
Imaging Mass hometry This concerns the
Upstream tissue processing here we did
some optimization we also establish
established standards to make
measurements comparable among machines
among many weeks um we invested a lot of
time in antibody validation and I will
come to that on the next slide I've
shown you how we can do the measurement
but then we also developed a comp uh a
brad computational toolbox to generate
the images to segment the images into
individual cells and then to do
Downstream data
analysis so now here I quickly want to
uh show you the types of antibodies that
we have already validated of course we
are centered on the topic of cancer and
therefore we have antibodies that tell
us the cell hoptic we can distinguish
many cell phenotypes immune cells stral
cells also different uh tumor cell types
we know cells are proliferative we can
measure many transcription factors that
informative about the C motility or the
inflammatory State th we can also tell
about the immune response we can tell
you the S cyto state or if there's a DNA
damage and repair mechanisms are ongoing
where we still have some uh troubles is
in measuring the metabolic State uh of
uh within the tissue by Imaging
myometry and besides that we also have I
would say about 40 antibodies that we
have validated against phosphation sites
so we can nicely read out the signaling
Network state of individual cells within
a tissue and all in all this sums up to
about 150 validated antibodies that we
know walk with imaging mass hometry and
at the very end I will also show you or
discuss with you on a couple of slides
how we actually do the
validation so here now a quick history
of Imaging
myometry when we started to develop the
this technique it took us about 14 hours
to image a square millimeter and the
image that you see here is from a breast
cancer um tissue uh in green you can see
her two which is typically at the
membrane we mentin which is noral the
droma in pink and ag3 which we use
sometimes as a nuclear marker shown in
blue and you can see that this image is
still kind of a blood then we improved
the reents we improved the protocols
image quality uh became better our
approach became faster then we build a
dedicated prototype Imaging system and
at that point it took us about five
hours to analyze a square
millimeter but more importantly the
images started to look similar to what
you will get with routine
immunofluorescent microscopy please note
on this image it's again a breast cancer
tissue section how we can nicely
demarcate individual cells and how her
to is nicely bound uh to the membrane
and there's no plin Etc so here I'm
often asked where's actually the
ventin and all this information is
actually contained in the data that we
generate but in imaging myometry we have
a very high dynamic range it's about 10
to the power of five which means that
you use the automatic Min Mark settings
to visualize the marker there sometimes
left with the impression that you
couldn't detect a given marker but then
if you adjust uh the scale you actually
see that there's Rich information
contained uh in the image and that is
compared to uh IHC of your resence
microscopy where you have perhaps a
dynamic range of 100 to to two a few
hundred so since then we sther improved
the technique um and by now routinely we
can analyze a square millimeter in in
about an hour and on this slide you see
a direct comparison between imun
floressence microscopy shown to the left
with imaging m ometry to the right and
to generate those images we again took a
breast cancer tissue section and we
stained it with an antibody against her
two and an antibody against cyto karatin
but before staining we split the
antibody labeled half with a
fluorochrome and the other half with a
metal isotope we mix the antibodies
again stain the tissue scanned it in the
fluoresence microscope which generated
the image to the left we took out the
very same tissue section and put it in
our Imaging mometer and scan the same
region and this generated the image to
the right where you seen false color the
distribution of the measured
Isotopes so there are several things
that we can now learn from this
comparison first really the distribution
and abundance of the measured markers is
basically identical between s microscopy
and imaging myometry and you also did
this comparison for IFC and you
basically get the same result you can
also see that uh Although our resolution
in our routine settings is about
threefold lower because you measure with
a a spot size of about a th000
nanometers while fluoresence microscopy
you're probably around 300
nanometers we nevertheless can nicely
see the membrane structure and and also
nuclei uh and the
cytoplasm however in our measurements we
we have information of over 40 markers
simultaneously now we also did a
quantification of the comparison between
Imaging myometry which is on the y- AIS
and immunofluoresence microscopy which
is on the xaxis we did this for many
markers and we can really see that the R
square so the correlation is at least 08
often it's higher but the difference um
between the two techniques can be
explained so if you look to the lower
right you can see that there many cells
that are very high in fluoresence
microscopy but low in signal in imaging
mom
and when we went back to those images to
find out what the cause is then the main
reason was the
autofluoresence of the tissue and as I
stated initially in imaging myometry we
do not suffer from
autofluoresence so now with with our
approach and the given throughput we can
also image larger areas here's the
breast cancer tissue where we analyze 44
antibodies simultaneously and you look
at an area of 4 * 2 mm and I just
quickly in in in a minute or so show you
how hetrogeneous and complex actually a
tumor can be and so what you see in the
moment is an unspecific metal counter
that we use to reveal tissue morphology
and to the right you can see uh this
large uh
bubbles um and these are actually fat
cells or to the lower left you see this
ground structure which we think was once
a duct that now is filled with tumor
cells so now we can lay the marker
expression as false color on top and
what you now can see on this slide are
for example small red dots and these are
actually cells that undergo mosis
because they high in phosphorated
histone H3 which is a metotic
marker now on this slide uh you can see
two different cyto carotin cyoar 5 in
blue cyto carotin 818 in green and pan
cyto carotin in red and in healthy
breast cyto carotin 5 and cyto carotin
818 delineate uh different lineages uh
of epicus cells but please note how in
the lower left area of this image these
two markers are incredibly
heterogeneously expressed uh in those
tumor cells and that really made it
clear to me for the first time visually
what tumor
heterogenity actually
means also looking at other markers here
we also have an antibody that gives us
an an epigenetic readout also here we
can see great uh cell phenotype
heterogenity but another aspect that I
want to highlight is here you can see in
green cd45 which is a p immune cell
marker and cd68 which can be a
mcroof marker and please note how there
are a lot of immune cells in the center
area and the lower right area of the
image but most mcroof FES are actually
in the upper left area or quadrant of
this
image and this also makes it clear that
within such a tumor there's not only a
great sell phenotype heterogenity but
also an enormous spatial
heterogenity in where different setps
are and how how they then interact with
each
other and this then obviously backs the
question how can we analyze uh these
data and over the last few years we
developed a toolbox that we call myad
which stands for Multiplex Imaging
citometry analysis
toolbox uh or in short myad in myad we
currently have four modules implemented
in the first module we can process the
images we identify individual cells the
neighborhoods but we can also do guting
on the images then we can push those
selected areas into our second module
where we have different algorithms to
study which cell phenotypes we have
present in the images in the third
module uh we develop novel algorithms
that on a global scale allow us to
analyze cellto cell interactions and
micro environments and in the fourth
module we can then relatest phenotypes
and cellto cell interactions with
clinical and patient
data and what I can also announce now is
that we have a stable better version
should you be interested in in testing
this toolbox we happy to share my C with
you and I also would like to stress that
not only works with imaging myometry
data but also with serial chromogenic or
fluorescent Imaging uh
approaches the last point is that myad
is really built in a user friendly and
intuitive Manner and when you for
example select a given cell type you can
readily see where those cells are
located in the tissue you can see their
neighborhoods once you select the
neighborhood you can immediately see
which cell types are part of that and
again where these are located on the
tissue
images now what is the current status of
Imaging myometry I told you that
routinely uh we need about an hour to
image square millimeter however we can
uh push the approach a bit and here in
mybe at least we can also measure square
millimeter in about 30 minutes the
resolution we routinely use uh a
micrometer spot size as this is for the
sweet spot for throughput
sensitivity uh and resolution of the
cellular compartments however we can
readily generate images at 500
nanometers or even at higher resolution
uh if you feel that it needed for
biological
question we can measure 52 markers
simultaneously and here is important to
stress that the technology itself
already supports now the ability to
measure 135 markers uh
simultaneously there's virtually no
overlap among the measurement channels I
told you about the large dynamic range
we can use frozen tissues formaline
fixed parine embedded tissue aan cells
so we we also uh use it for bone samples
so all the tissue types that are
typically used in lense research we can
analyze by Imaging Mass ometry
sensitivity is probably in the range of
100 copies per pixel uh I told you that
we have about 150 antibodies
analyzed and the whole approach is PL
and play with the mometer and also soon
a commercial uh system will be available
uh that can be purchased by uh anyone to
do imaging mass hometry at their own uh
facilities or Labs or
company on the last few slides I want to
give you a few examples of what we can
do with imaging M hometry so in one
study we uh are analyzing a cohort of
breast cancer samples for every patient
we have two areas of the tumor core of
the invive front of the available of the
Met metastatic size is available and
then match tissue and of course we have
um a lot of clinical information
available in in
addition so then typically we first look
at the cell phenotypes and here I would
like to stress on this slide you do not
see a tissue section but what you see is
a projection of the Single Cell
phenotypes from the high dimensional in
two-dimensional space using an algorithm
called te and to explain this to you
every tiny dot is is an individual cell
and if two cells are very close to each
other that simply means that the mark
expression was very similar and the mark
expression shown here for estrogen
receptor per two saratin tine and ecarin
can be then shown in in a color scale
where here blue is lowest and red
highest expression of a given
marker now what I found truly
fascinating is there are three three
clusters three cell phenotype clusters
driven by three patients that were all
classified as luminal Bop positive
patients but if you only look at
estrogen receptor you can already
appreciate that it's lower expressed
than in patient one then if you look at
her two patient two has lower levels in
patient one and three the same is true
for the cyto carotin and eeran is much
higher expressed in patient three
compared to the other two patients
and then you look at all the other uh 40
uh something markers that we measured
here uh you would be surprised to see
how different those three patients are
from each other and that is something
that we now see over and over again
while the classification using just two
markers and doing a kind of yes and no
classification um is already very useful
in the clinics and our technology nicely
reproduces that uh we did this many
times if you start to look
quantitatively at those markers and many
others on top you actually see that
these tissues and therefore tumors can
be actually quite distinct uh from each
other so we can then also use clustering
algorithms to identify cell phenotype
clusters here we used the phenograph um
and we identified 29 cell phenotypic
clusters in the cohort uh of these
breast cancer
samples and in the next step we want to
know whether we can identify patterns of
cellto cell interactions in those
tissues or to refres it whether there
are certain micro environments whether
there certain structure in the tissue
that we can
identify and for this we developed
several algorithms they also implemented
in mad that allow us to perform a
systematic neighborhood analysis over
all the cell types that we can Define
using algorithms or also manual
and what we do is that for every single
cell we determine its nearest neighbor
so you can also uh Define a radius then
we do some statistics of which cells we
actually find and then we develop
algorithms that give you as an output
that certain neighborhoods are enriched
in a tissue or that certain cellto cell
interactions are actually avoided in a
tissue which is as important to describe
the structure of a
tissue and we did this here as an
example for 52 uh patient samples the
red shows the interaction and the blue
the avoidance of two cells being next to
other on the x-axis you see all the
combinations of all cell phenotype
clusters versus all phenotype clusters
and on the y- AIS you see the individual
samples and in white you see tumors that
we great one and in Black tumors that
are grade three and you can readily see
that these actually uh separate
according to the clinical status and
then we look closer we can see that this
is driven by the actual cellto cell
interaction structure that we have
identified in those images uh such an
heat map is very
informative uh gives you a Grand View uh
on the data but we typically then
transform this using also a set of
algorithms that we implemented uh in the
form uh of a network because that's
easier to interpret
and now what can one can readily see is
that the great one tumors they show a
lot of structure as there's a lot of
cellto cell interactions uh and a lot of
cellto cell avoidance while the great
sweet tumor has much less of of of this
type of structure then when you look
closer we see here this uh note number
three that's actually a tumor phenotype
and you see that it has a very strong
interaction with itself and that makes a
lot of sense because in the grer tumors
uh the the tumor tissue is still very
well structured so these cells interact
readily with each other and also the
interactions that we find in this
network are often with other tumor cell
types now in the cor three tumor you can
appreciate that uh the cell phenotype
number three does not show any more uh
uh interaction or avoidance with other
cell types Now what is interesting in
the great number three tumor is the side
cluster number seven which is a tumor
Associated mcroof cluster in qu one we
didn't find any significant interactions
however then here in the qu three tumor
we see that their structure in where
those cells are actually located within
a tissue and for example cluster 14 that
you see then to the low right to Cluster
seven these are cells that are in highly
hypoxic areas and we do not find the
mcro fases being close to that now I
could explain you a lot more about the
biology that we identified here but the
point that I want to make is if the
algorithms that we have now developed
together with imaging Mass hometry we
can perform a comprehensive neighborhood
analysis that reveals a the structure
and structural differences down to the
cell type and the cell to cell
interactions and then we only a single
step away from using this data to
stratify patients according to clinical
data and also here we implemented
different approaches the example that I
show you here is based on the citus
algorithm that was developed by Rob
brockner and then we compare here the
grade three with the gr one uh tumor
images we actually find that unique to
gr one uh is again a cluster of of the
tumor cells again with specific spal
properties and the cluster that is
unique for GR three tumor is actually
high in cd60 mentin so these are again
the macro fures of which you have seen
before also that have a unique micro
environment and what we uh strongly now
propose is that you should really use
the cell types and cellto cell
interactions as biomarkers uh to
classify patients uh for the subsequent
treatment
Etc now where do we go from here
um I told you initially that a tumor is
a highly complex entity and in a moment
we only analyze uh slices meaning we
generate images however to understand a
given cell phenotype I'm convinced that
we also need threedimensional
information because the red cell that
I've highlighted here with errors we
might only understand its sell state if
we know about the cells above or below
uh the cell and therefore what we have
now developed um in my group is what we
call Mass tomography and so we use the
Imaging Mass citometry approach to
generate threedimensional
volumes uh of of tumors and I hope that
you can actually in the moment see the
animation of this
tumor at the same time
okay now in addition we then also have
developed a computational toolbox which
we call my cat 3D um that allows us to
generate those 3D volumes from Imaging
Mass hometry measurement um and also
then to do data analysis uh in those
threedimensional volumes and just here
quickly another video where we generated
a larger volume again of a breast cancer
tumor
okay and then you could actually see
that we have the resolution uh in in the
boxal space uh to see individual nuclei
and cells uh so that we can really do 3D
segmentation of the cells and therefore
then truly understand the environment of
every cell in three
dimensions so now coming uh back to to
antibodies
um validating antibodies is an enormous
effort it takes a lot of time sometimes
a lot of neres and obviously a lot of uh
uh Financial Resources to validate dust
and d and d of
antibodies and we eventually thought
that it is a waste if all of this
validation data is an only kept uh
within a given
laboratory and therefore what we have
developed is a data
that is called aab um if you go to the
aab website you can make your own
account and aab has two important sites
there's a the private side that is for
the laboratory only you can organize all
your antibodies you can do antibody
purchases you can uh tell which label
your antibodies have you can make panels
of antibodies for mass at ometry for
flowetry so you can really organize your
whole antibody library with airlab but
the for me the most important point of
airlab is that to every
antibody you can attach validation data
so you can say here's the tetration
against positive and negative cells or
here's the experiment that we
overexpress the marker and all of this
data you can attach to an antibody clone
or or um a a batch of antibod that you
have labeled and upon publication we
hope that people will make this
information available to the community
and we make this very easy because
there's basically a Buton a button where
you can say make public and all of the
validation information about a given
antibody is shared with the scientific
community and so in the medium term we
truly hope that airlab will become
something akin to an antibody Wikipedia
and we truly hope that this will save a
lot of time spent uh on antibody
validation uh in other
labs now also just quickly about
antibody validation we found that the
metal labeling hardly ever affects
antibody specificity if any it destroys
the antibody alog together we always
follow the rules of validation that were
outlined by Dr vetzel in the last
presentation it's very tedious to do all
of those
experiments uh but you all know the
saying garbage in garbage out so better
make sure there's no garage which going
in um we readily use immun resence
microscopy in ASD to pretest and
validate antibodies with highr and once
we see an antibodies very promising we
label it and push it to the uh
revalidation with imaging M
hometry then there are also many rules
uh to design a panel of 40 antibodies to
get truly high quality
data
and obviously one always needs to have
many controls uh the right controls to
validate antibodies but always having
many controls that validate the
performance of the antibodies when you
actually do an
experiment and with this I would like to
come to the acknowledgement uh here's a
picture of my team and uh people say
they're only standing on the shoulders
of a giant I'm standing on the shoulders
uh of my whole Lab they really do a
fantastic job and about half of them now
are work uh in the direction of Imaging
myometry the other half is working uh in
the direction of suspension myometry uh
and simply thanks to all of them for for
their wonderful job and then I also want
to acknowledge my collaborators and
finding agencies and here especially the
LA lab of deas Gunter who to initially
to start Imaging myometry uh was was a
key person and then I also want to
greatly acknowledge University Hospitals
of turich and Basel
um for their support in terms of the
samples and here's specifically Susan
Vaga and especially wter vber who is at
University Hospital of Basel and an
incredible supporter of of biomedical
research and I also want to acknowledge
uh the Swiss National Science Foundation
the European research Council and the ni
as being the main funding agencies of my
group and uh finally also the PATH
foundation which is uh a tissue bio bank
that was founded by patients that
actually want that their samples are
used for
research and that's an amazing
Foundation as they're incredibly
supportive uh to make available sample
Collections and clinical data and with
this I'm done and uh we are happy to
receive your
questions thank you for that informative
presentation Professor buen Miller
before we get started on the question
and answer session I would like to
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and we will
answer any remaining questions by email
including questions that are submitted
after the live event okay our first
question is given the instruments are
not easily available can you comment on
the difference in throughput and
sensitivity between your method and the
multi
omix
so I assume the reference to the
multiomics approach is is the one from
uh GE Healthcare and so the multiomics
approach um is based on serial
fluorescent
microscopy and there are several
advantages of seral fluorescent
microscopy images of tissues and there
are several
disadvantages uh let me start with the
advantages the advant AG certainly is
the screw put because in this approach
you label one two three there's now one
publication with five antibodies at the
same time and then you can take a slide
scanner and image really large areas of
the
tissues um that's an an enormous plus
the caveat of the approach is that it's
a cyclic method meaning that you have to
add the antibodies to the tissue you
have to image you have to remove the
tissues uh at the antibodies then again
you have to stain image again remove the
antibodies and it has been seen that due
to the cyclic nature um it's very time
consuming and many epitopes lose the
antigenicity the morphology of the
tissue can change so these are the main
challenges of the serial fluorescent
microscopy
technique however and and also the
dyamic range of fluorescent approaches
uh and the autofluoresence of a tissue
but uh for me personally the way I see
it um having a technique like serial
fluorescent
microscopy I I see in the moment as a
great tool to get a good overview of a
tissue already very informative and then
zoom into the most informative parts of
the tissues with imaging Mass hometry to
get the highly quantitative data with
the simultaneously stained antibodies on
the
tissue okay and this one is for you
Baron how is size measured in the ion
Cloud so when we analyze tissues we do
not measure uh any size when you analyze
individual cells then um the length of
the ion signal that you can detect is
roughly correlated uh to the size of a
given cell and we now also have reents
established in mic group that actually
give a very accurate readout of the
volume of a cell but we haven't
published that yet but that should soon
be uh out I hope keep fingers
crossed okay and this is for you too it
is great to sting sections with 52
antibodies is there any saturation limit
for number of antibodies cells can take
or antibody antibody
interaction so that's an excellent
question and and a question I frequently
hear
um so I cannot give a quantitative
answer to that um what I can say is that
during the validation process uh we look
at individual antibodies at few
antibodies and at all the antibodies at
the same time and if there were steric
hindrances or
influences then we would for example see
that the signals of all the antibodies
would go down of many of them and that's
not something we have observed yet and
also in the tissue section one has to
think that it's uh I exaggerate but it's
a two-dimensional entity so there's a
lot of space on top and to the bottom in
where the antibodies can be but then
also after antigen retrieval I think a
tissue often if you really look into it
with an electron microscope looks rather
like a Swiss cheese a closed tissue so I
think there's a lot of space for
antibodies having said that we have seen
steric hindrances for antibodies that
Target the same protein for example
phosphorilation side and the total
protein and there we actually can can
see such effects but not over the whole
panel uh in
general for the laser based sampling are
you going to get one single cell or CL
cluster of cells and if the samples are
composed of multiple cells how to
accurately put every single cell to its
right location during image
reconstruction so the resolution of the
laser is such that we have subcellular
resolution so a typical tumor cell I
would say is probably about 20
micrometers in diameter or even
sometimes larger and our spot size of
the laser is about a micrometer that
means that we measure for every
individual cell about 400 pixels at a
minimum and the Reconstruction of the
images is done in a way that we know the
coordinates of every individual laser
shot that is recorded it's a bit
oversimplified but that's in the end
what it's done and afterwards we can
simply uh use this coordinates to
generate a quit which reflects every
single laser shot uh that was performed
on the tissue and then we can fill into
each spot of the grid the information
about Mark expression and that's when we
have the image uh of of the
tissue so that step is actually
extremely
simple okay are these stained ffp or FF
tissue
slides
so as I mentioned in the
presentation uh the technology itself
does not care a lot about the sample
type you offer it for Imaging and what I
showed was formaline fixed paraffine and
bettered tissues where we then had to do
antigen retrieval etc etc but we also
image Frozen tissue sections uh orer and
cell lines or even cells that you stand
in suspension you attach to a surface so
all of this we can analyze it's it's
only about buying in the antibodies to
your sample of interest and that is
something independent of our technology
really okay
great okay bear with me one second I'm
just grabbing another question for
you um if this is a practical question
when IMC is used for FST do you need
pre-treatment St steps like anti
retrieval uh yes that is correct um we
do uh higher retrieval so so so heat
induced uh and we do it in uh at basic
pH um and this already touches uh the
topic of uh how to generate an antibody
panel because uh as Dr vetel already
pointed out antibodies have certain
Optima
also in terms of the antigen retrieval
and in imaging M ometry you have to find
your roughly 50 antibodies that all
perform pretty well at a single antigen
retrieval
condition well that will be have to be
our last question for today but I'd like
to remind everyone that we will answer
all the remaining questions by email um
including those that are submitted after
this live webinar I would like to once
again thank DRS bu Miller and wetel for
their presentations do either of you
have any final
comments no thank you I would just like
to say thanks to everyone for uh
listening in
today and also I would like to thank
everyone for for joining this webinar
and thanks for your really good
questions well thank you both and I
would also like to thank our sponsor
cell signaling technology for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for on
demand viewing through June 2017 you'll
receive an email from labroots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
and we will see you here next time at
lab roots.com
goodbye